[Music]
jake we are planning on having a little
meeting today to talk about what we were
gonna make a cyberpunk video on this
week
and well you know what sometimes uh some
news just falls right into your lap
cyberpunk has been delayed once again
for the
third time uh you have the official
dates
originally it was in april yeah so
originally was supposed to launch april
16th
my birthday that was a big bummer when
that got pushed
then it was september 17th then it was
november 19th and now
it is december 10th so it's not a big
delay it's about three weeks 21 days
i i think we can make it but there are
some bigger implications to this that we
kind of wanted to get into can i have a
little discussion about because i know a
lot of people are bummed
but i think they have a good reason to
delay it yeah looking at their uh their
twitter announcement the big reason they
talked about
in the delay is trying to get it ready
for
all these new consoles i think something
they probably weren't anticipating
uh with you know how many times they've
delayed it is that they are now
launching on
next-gen consoles essentially uh so they
have to make sure that the
versions of cyberpunk are going to be
compatible with
the xbox series xns and the ps5 i mean
those games have or those systems have
backwards compatibility
uh and even though like in theory it
would just work there's always little
you know potential tweaks and
incompatibility stuff that they need to
figure out and i think
i imagine that they just realize like a
lot of people are gonna be playing these
games
on their ps5 we need to make sure these
versions uh
are are you know gonna be like fully
functioning versions of the game
now that doesn't mean that the next gen
updates for the games are gonna be
available day one they
haven't said anything about that i
imagine that is still
probably not coming until next year
totally and i think you really hit the
nail on the head with
the fact that a lot of people maybe not
a vast majority of people but many
people are picking up an xbox series x a
ps5
in order to play cyberpunk on it right
like even though sure you can play on
ps4 you can't play on
xbox one x i think a lot of people are
kind of thinking of this game as the
first next-gen game
in some ways and i think it makes sense
as to why they'd want to make sure that
this game is running smooth on
everything and two right you have to
consider that
there are two xbox consoles launching
this time instead of one
and there is one playstation 4 but there
or playstation 5 but there are two
versions of that
so i i think it makes sense am i
disappointed
yeah a little bit i was really looking
forward to playing it
john luke and i have been doing a ton of
videos covering cyberpunk and both of us
are very excited for it
but honestly if they're not ready and
they want to push it back a couple weeks
if they think that's enough time
to get it where it needs to be for these
next-gen consoles
i'm cool with that yeah i mean think
about
like i think the bright the way i would
think about it is like this thing is
coming out you know
right before winter break that is like
the perfect time
to really just dive deep into cyberpunk
you know for like
i mean uh i can't deny that i'm
a little excited that it got delayed
just because it was going to come out
during the middle of console launch
season and because of our jobs
uh the idea that i can devote more time
to cyberpunk
is uh appealing to me personally so
um while it is it is sad there is that
silver lining that i
i think about that way but that does
bring up the other
idea that um how is this going to affect
game of the year uh yes so that was the
next thing i was going to mention that
jeff keeley tweeted that cyberpunk will
not be
in the 2020 video game awards show
which is kind of to be expected they did
the same thing with super smash bros a
couple years ago because that also
launched in december
so it looks like we'll have to wait
until 2021 to see how cyberpunk fares
and jeff keeley's video game awards
however whether or not it will show up
in other game of the year
awards like ours for example is kinda
we're not entirely sure yet i'm sure
you'll hear more as we know more
but the big game awards show is is
putting cyberpunk on hold yeah i mean i
i can't imagine how many
games are like so excited about that you
know like uh we have a chance now to
beat game of the year or
just to have like a a a free launch
window like i you know i'm
i'm a big destiny 2 player and that
game's new expansion was coming
right dab in the middle of cyberpunk's
launch and i was like ah poor destiny
this game is going to get
buried but now i actually have time to
play it so um
i'm just trying to think on the positive
side of it jake you know like
that's all i can do right now well even
though cyberpunk has been delayed that
doesn't mean we are going to stop making
cyberpunk videos here on gamespot we
will be doing weekly cyberpunk updates
make sure to come back for that we also
have our lore videos that me and jake
have been doing so you can expect
even more of those i still have that
furries video that people have been
asking for so
you can expect that at some point soon
and yeah as further
cyberpunk developments happen uh you can
expect all of that right here on
gamespot
[Music]
you